TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
We recently announced
a set of new features
to make it easier for users to
find, interact, and reengage
with your app on
Google Assistant.
Details are on the post,
linked the description below.
Back in September, we worked
with Hackster.io to encourage
y'all to build smart, connected
devices using Android Things
and post your projects to the
Developer Challenge for Android
Things.
The winners are in, and you can
check them out on this post.
The developer preview
of TensorFlow Lite
is now available.
It's TensorFlows
lightweight solution
for mobile and
embedded devices that
enables low latency inference
of on-device machine learning
models.
Tensorflow Lite is lightweight,
cross-platform, and fast.
Take a look at the
post for everything
you need to get started.
As part of TensorFlow
Lite, we also
released an on-device
conversational model
and a demo app that provides an
example of a natural language
application powered
by TensorFlow Lite.
We hope this will
make it easier for you
to build new machine
intelligence features powered
by on-device inference.
SLING is an experimental system
for parsing natural language
text directly into a
representation of its meaning
as a semantic frame graph.
The output frame graph
directly captures
the semantic
annotations of interest
to the user while avoiding the
pitfalls of pipelined systems
by not running any
intermediate stages.
DialogFlow Enterprise Edition
is now available in beta.
It expands on all the
benefits of DialogFlow,
offering greater
flexibility and support
to meet the needs of
large scale businesses.
We also announced speech
integration within DialogFlow,
enabling you to build rich,
voice-based applications.
Check out the post
for more details.
Cloud Spanner multi-region
configurations
are now generally available.
With this release, we've
extended Cloud Spanner's
transactions and
synchronous replication
across regions and continents.
That means no matter
where your users may
be, apps backed by Cloud
Spanner can read and write
up-to-date data globally, and
do so with minimal latency
for end users.
Container-diff is a tool
for quickly comparing
container images, and
it's now open source.
The GitHub link is on the post.
Firebase Cloud Messaging is
a cross-platform messaging
solution that reliably
delivers messages at no cost.
It sends over 400
billion messages per day.
We've recently announced a new
RESTful API, the Firebase Cloud
Messaging HTTP v1 API that
makes it safer and easier
to send messages to your
cross-platform applications.
Examples are on the post,
linked in the description below.
We're excited to announce
Google Developers Launchpad
Africa, our new hands-on
comprehensive mentorship
program tailored exclusively
to startups based in Africa.
Applications are due on December
11, 9:00 AM Pacific time,
and the first class will
start in early 2018.
Please like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching another
episode of The Dev Show.
If you'd like to catch some
of our previous episodes,
they're right over here.